all right Riley Riley where'd you grow
up where you from originally I am from
San Diego California and tell me about
your childhood did both your parents
when you were kid yeah I have both my
parents it was a very like modern family
structure but they were both in the
picture and no traumatic events no no
abuse nothing like that no no my I mean
my mom was more of a weekend mom and my
dad was the full-time parent but not
much Americans pretty normal okay kid
were you in high school I'm sorry what
kind of kid were you in high school
I was I would say like a B average
Karen's got a normal kid you know I did
I danced in high school I did like hip
hop dance and step team and normal
upbringing no this I mean chill I had
the same boyfriend all through high
school so I was like the good girl and
so you went on your own and what you
left your parents house Atwood and 19
mm-hmm and where'd you go from there
I actually went to school actually went
to college yeah I went to say our Mesa
College in San Diego which was the
Community College and then I went to
Arizona State after that so today you're
working as now I'm in the adult industry
I do like social media I do cam like web
cam things like that most of it's all
like online based adult entertainment
how did you start in this um be online
stuff
no it just just in general in general um
I was working just a normal corporate
job and I hated it I just woke up every
day I was like I'm miserable so and I
had some friends who were in there down
the stree and it just always fascinated
me I was always intrigued by the adult
industry and I just asked people I was
really good friends with with this guy
who was in the game and I'm like I want
you to make me the baddest [ __ ] in the
game and that's and from then on it just
kind of it kind of just down whoa what
do you think about sex work attracted
you
it's clearly not for everyone right it's
not for everybody I think it's the power
it's the power behind it like knowing
that you own your body and it's uh if I
don't know it's it's the whole like it's
also the game of it like being able to
get somebody to pay you for something
that everyone else is giving away for
free if I use a self esteem boost
it's a self esteem of boosts it's a it's
a power trip it's also like the money's
like this you know I mean so you get it
really fast and you're living a life
that our parents won't even dream of oh
yeah sure I hear that a lot
yeah so how did you start he started as
a just working girl actually started off
as cuz I did massage therapy for a while
so I actually started just doing like
happy ending massages and then that kind
of turned into what else would you do
now how much more do you have so it kind
of just went from there and I got into
full-on escorting at that point and then
I started posting ads and just booking
dates at that point so mostly online
stuff yeah mostly in the beginning it
was just back page I really did back
then July ever worth the street I did
but not till later actually kind of did
it backwards for most typically we go
the other way yeah yeah actually did it
later because of some incidences that
happen with the guy I was dealing with I
had to be a little more low-key and I
couldn't be so out there because he was
fighting a federal indictment and I I
started hitting the streets because I
didn't want my face out there as much so
I moved to Miami for awhile when he was
locked up and I was walking the streets
of Miami getting money and hitting bars
and hitting hotels have you been
arrested before yeah I've been arrested
in Denver I got escorting without a
license out there and then I got to
prostitution charges in San Diego but
unless it was early on it was like the
first six months and I haven't been
arrested since and our drugs part of the
picture for you no no I mean nothing
hardcore I don't consider marijuana a
drug it's I think alcohol is worse than
that so I've smoked weed but no I mean
I've tried Somali and but nothing but
maybe two or three times like
that's it so you version temp I'm sorry
you've worked with him before
yeah I did my first the first time by
gel was his name was pimp see he was
that a big name that was the guy that
made me the baddest [ __ ] in the game
and we just kind of went from there we
were actually really good friends for a
few months I was six or seven months
before I decided like that's what I
wanted to deal with so I actually chose
to deal with him 27 years old and I was
like so you you chose him rather than a
medically he didn't like trick you into
doing this no no he was just a friend I
just watched how he moved and I
respected his reputation I respected the
way that he handled himself so it seemed
like the best most what's the attraction
for for a girl to go with a pal um well
when just like you go to college you
have to pay for an education so for me
it was like I wanted to have all the
game that he had and the only way I was
gonna really do that in the beginning
that's it was like I respected him and I
trusted him and I just wanted everything
that he had to offer like his mind was
really what I was buying into it that's
the yeah what to do with all that stuff
you guys I'm going to post the ad he
taught me how to talk to talk to tricks
and you know how to get along with other
girls to make my life easier to just the
do's and do nots and you have to you
have to pay for that just like I would
have to pay for any education at any
tuition or institution or university so
right hmm and it was a book so you give
him what what part of the money all of
it oh and you get out of it as well um
the education the expertise and your
Oliver amber and the companionship of
having somebody that you know that
you're it's you and him and whatever
family you have that you've built I'll
try and dry
ya know he still takes care of you funny
yeah absolutely I mean I would come home
to new clothes and new purses I mean he
spoiled the hell out of me yeah well
he's back yeah it seems like a lot of
people want to make it an extreme like
you give him all your money you get
nothing else yeah no we and we had a
plan you know I mean we knew exactly
what we were going with it and and it
was all and we just respected and had
it's a it's a different type of love
it's a different type of respect so that
was a
going relationship how long that lasts
or is it still going on um we were yeah
cuz he he went to jail about six months
after I was dealing with him and um I
stayed with him it wasn't like four or
five years while he was in jail went
through the whole like federal
indictment together
he had a RICO conspiracy that he was
fighting and so yeah I was with him to
that but looking back at that
relationship you don't go like oh you
took advantage of me no at all right no
do you kid I don't know and do you find
this lifestyle gets in the way of
romantic relationships for you um I
think the issue with the romantic
relationship is is more just don't say
it's a lifestyle because some guys are
into it but um it's more me being able
to open up to men because then you have
so many men that are willing to pay you
so much money it's hard to be like doing
it for free I mean so it's it I could
say yeah it can be it can be a struggle
and are you saving money yeah oh for
sure for sure in the beginning I wasn't
yeah but by being a higher end yeah girl
you you end up making oh yeah I mean
when I so I retired a little while ago I
found not escorting anymore cuz I'm
doing a lot of webcam stuff but yeah I
got up to about $1,000 hour I was
minimum I'm not showing up unless you
have that no I mean I'm about to buy my
first house I Drive a really nice car
but dealing with somebody in the
beginning who taught me the value of
building a lifestyle definitely makes a
difference because we it's almost like
the the the pimps like Tim C or bishop
or other high-end you know more more
respected pimps almost groom you for
absolutely a better quality of life I
would probably be worse off with I was
still working at the cell phone company
I wasn't saving anything there yeah
because I was just get my paycheck and
spinning yeah I'm bills are you you're
happy you would describe it oh I'm Way
happier now on the Dalton issue and I
seem to be right yeah what personality
traits do you think you possess that
that help you do this because a lot of
girls couldn't do this right no it's not
for everybody
um you have to have a self driven
attitude within yourself
like no one else especially with him
being locked up for so long no one else
made me wake up in the morning and go do
what I needed to do so just like if you
had any job you had your own business
you have to get up and you have to work
at everything you do every day and the
Sun comes up you're up Sun Goes Down
you're still up you know so you just
that's a big thing I think girls think
oh I have I have a [ __ ] so someone's
gonna pay for it but that's the
difference between being a 200 dollar ho
and being a thousand dollar escort so I
think it makes a big difference when you
work at your own your own craft what do
you think the most misunderstood thing
about doing this kind of work you know
because there's a range of yeah I've had
both you have for sure you have the ones
that they're doing it's us to pay for
their drugs and other ones who are doing
I think one of the one of the pimps send
me a text and he said she's 7,000 an
hour or 7,000 for an evening or
something yeah I mean yeah cuz that's
where I was at for the whole night it's
just there's definitely different levels
to this shape but I think the biggest
misconception is that people will where
I'm at in my price range and where I was
doing when I retired I think people
think that they're forced into it I
think girls sometimes take that take
that victim role because it's easier for
them to deal with law enforcement and
it's better to say somebody made me do
it than to say I'm a proud ho so I think
being able to like own it but a lot I
think that's the biggest exception that
somebody made you do this now you're
free to leave whenever you want I mean
I'm sure there's some gorilla pimps that
make that there are definitely some
gorilla pimps out there for sure the
pimping role is yeah just like that
wider range of any career I've ever seen
yeah just like I mean just like the
girls you're gonna have low-end girls
you're lowing guys yeah yeah it was the
worst time of your life but worth um in
my life
like during the game I guess I made
related to this were there certain times
where we just got frustrating him it got
really frustrating when when he first
got locked up because I had to learn a
new way to do it to stay under the radar
and not being able to get on the phone
and speak to him
we used to like used to be like hey I'm
dealing with this how do I move this way
and we would come up with a plan to
figure it out you know or I could call
somebody and be like you know this
dude's not paying me like I had to do it
all on my own
and that was probably the hardest time
I'm like prison for how long seven years
total almost seven years yet so when
when you're PIM PIM see what was was put
in prison I mean was there pressure on
you to just to kind of tell him tell her
oh yeah for sure for sure
I've actually got subpoenaed to testify
against him and mind you this was
already three and a half years into him
being in prison because it took them
that long to even get him a trial so
once we got to the trial factor yeah
they tried to subpoena me to go testify
to actually even try to scare me like
you could be charged with all the same
things he's charged with they try to
tell me the same thing with where we
come from like I'm like where I'm from
southeast San Diego like we have a
different code and just you just don't
tell if you do the you know you do the
crime do the time type of thing and I
was not gonna snitch sorry I chose this
how can I put that on so you never do
know I actually had to go out and get a
lawyer and literally tell them like hey
we're in the worth still in the statute
of limitation she's not testifying go
ahead and charge her if you have to and
I got all suited I literally saw that
they were gonna make me go on stand
anyways I got all the way dressed up was
there everyday is trial and there like
binary lawyer contacted us so we don't
really need you we have enough already
but I just think that's so big
especially coming from the neighborhood
in the community in the game and just
street and look growing up in South East
San Diego like that's so big as so many
people are so so easily turned
especially and they don't realize that
the government is going to or
prosecutors are going to try to make you
say stuff even if they don't have
anything on you you know that means
that's like and kiss my ass talk to my
lawyer
you know I mean like I wasn't going to
never would never would it was the best
time of your life when I was able to say
when I was able to train
from saying I'm just the street hunted
Allah ho to being like that first that
first time that someone hands you a
couple thousand dollars like that's such
a sex such a high such a rush like when
you walk when you come home with $20,000
and like it's consistently happening
that's not on like that and then just no
one like there was an end date for him
that he was coming home cuz that at one
point was looking at life so no one that
he's coming home and no one money is
getting better and like we were me I had
this plan when he comes out like that
was like a big thing too for just no no
but we're gonna be okay
it was probably happiest time during the
game how do you think doing this kind of
work for your most of your a lot of you
I'm 34 I started at 27 I was much older
when I got into the case started late
yeah I started late how do you think
doing this has changed you I think gave
me a lot more confidence a lot more
confidence like and the greatest part is
I have a family that supports me with it
I kinda have to hide it from my family
oh really
my mom knows my brother's know everyone
knows they're cool with it yeah they
found out when I was working out the
bunny ranch it's kind of hard to hide
when you're you worked up in Reno I did
yeah I worked that I strength I've I'm
pretty out there as far as social media
like I don't hide it
cuz I'm I'm a big believer in if you're
an adult woman and you make this
decision it's nobody else's choice it's
your body if you feel like you want to
charge it for it go for it and I just
want them people to feel like they're
safe when I make that up and make that
choice you ever stand back and look at
your life and just go wow this is nuts
I want to say this is nuts it's a it's
more of like I all like look what you
did you're proud of it absolutely yeah
yeah cuz I'm I don't want to follow the
same things that my parents had to do
they're still in debt they're still
almost 60 working like I don't I want to
have the freedom to do what I want when
I want and being able to do this let
make that possible
and where do you see your life going
like in the next like five years do you
see yourself married with kids or did
you enjoy doing this I wouldn't mind
like I don't know I guess that would
just depend on who I'm you know who I'm
dealing with that time but I don't think
kids I would love to have kids but I
don't think that I could like there with
doctors and stuff it's been said that I
don't I'm probably not gonna have kids
it's gonna be a battle like I'd have to
go through like an vitro and stuff like
that so probably not kids I have God
kids and nieces and nephews that fill
that void for me but yeah I definitely
to be married one day for sure so so the
technology has taken hold with the
industry and you're now doing and I'm
doing a lot of webcam a lot of webcam
that seems to be the way of the future
yeah and that's kind of it cuz it's
safer at me and I'll have to touch
anybody I'm making twice as much money
so I mean I have the choice that if I
want to take a date I can but I don't
have to anymore you know to like make
the money so you still do but but you
don't have to yeah I don't anymore I've
got to the point where I'm pretty
comfortable oh I see okay yes I don't
have to but yeah I know most of us like
webcam I do like subscription-based
stuff everything's web web now it's it's
it's making it safer for the industry
and it's making it more acceptable to a
lot of people are more open-minded to
the adult industry because of webcam
because of porn industry isn't supp like
that I mean so you worked on the street
kind of the lower end yeah I started off
taking $100 for cookies so so tell me
the difference between that end of the
spectrum to the higher end where you're
getting making thousands um try thing
like how to I mean obviously the
clientele is different so you're dealing
with a lot less problems um when you're
dealing with the hunt you're just kind
of in and out you're dealing with a lot
of like construction guys or and they're
out there and they're out so it's like a
lot more traffic you're obviously doing
a lot more toll on your body and stuff
like that but um but it was it was fun
I'm not gonna lie it was fun like it was
fun to be like boom out blue when you're
here boom you're next to like just like
I'm like coming home every day like look
how much I made I was just excited was
gonna shopping on the weekends it's
something like it was it was fun I like
I kind of miss it sometimes I miss
hustle and bustle of it but I mean I
mean once I had to change something once
he got locked up because I couldn't keep
doing that they were gonna watch
everything that we did so and you find
doing this for your your career is it
affects your yourself it makes you
depressed or anything like that no
probably the opposite yeah I mean like
somebody handed me $5,000 to hang out
with them who doesn't get a boost out of
that I mean there's other girls hanging
out with them all weekend for free you
know I don't know that's definitely a
power trip 74 shorter all right Riley
thank you so much for talking know about
homes very interesting thank you for for
all your honesty and every thank you
retain it
you